we're going to return to the breaking
news i've brought you a few moments ago
that's concerning the
police officer uh who has been convicted
of the manslaughter of former footballer
dalian atkinson today he has been
sentenced
to eight years in prison you may
remember some of the details of the case
uh dalian atkinson um in an altercation
with his officer outside his father's
home in telford shropshire
uh he uh well the police officer
discharged a taser three times and
kicked him in the head
twice the court heard it was a very
disturbing evidence that was given skies
becky johnson has been following the
case she's outside birmingham crown
court now um
and a sentence of eight years uh handed
down becky yes pc
benjamin monk from west mercier police
jailed for eight years for the
manslaughter of dalian atkinson
the judge telling him as he jailed him
that
he was sure that the kicks that pc monk
delivered to dalian atkinson's head
were a contributory factor to his death
and he said that in handing down a
sentence he had to have in mind
that the public entrust powers to police
and the sentence given to pc monk must
reflect the importance
of maintaining trust in police pc monk
of course the first
police officer in england to be
convicted of manslaughter for an act in
the line of duty for over
30 years now beginning that eight year
jail sentence and there were tears
from mr atkinson's partner as once again
the judge went over the details of this
terrible case
it was almost five years ago when police
were called to the street where daley
and atkinson's father lived
dalian atkinson the judge reminded the
court today
was acting completely out of character
he had of course had a hugely
successful career as a footballer most
notably with aston villa but also
playing with other clubs was well loved
by many fans but his health had
deteriorated
and he was neighbors called the police
there was then a confrontation pc monk
tasered him for some 33 seconds
the normal cycle of a taser is just five
seconds and then delivered
those kicks to mr atkinson's head
those kicks delivered with such force
that the imprint of pc
monk's boot lace was found in two places
on dalian atkinson's forehead and he
died
a short time later for mr atkinson's
family
this trial has been incredibly harrowing
they've had to
relive all those terrible details of
what happened that night the judge said
that
from the statements that mr atkinson's
family have given to the court
he can see that none of them can come to
terms with their loss and i've been
speaking
to dalian atkinson's long-term partner
karen wright this was
her reaction to what she's heard in this
court over recent weeks
the whole trial has been harrowing
seeing his clothes
in exhibit bags after i've seen them go
on his back
in the bedroom that morning uh when he
put the clothes on to then seeing them
where it's just been harrowing if we've
got brutality on our streets by people
that we
rely on in the you know then the justice
system needs to
serve justice
we are expecting shortly some reaction
to this sentence from mr
atkinson's family when pc monk was
convicted last week
they spoke of their relief they said
that on that night
dalian atkinson needed help for his
mental health
and instead he was kicked in the head by
a police officer so we'll wait to see
what their reaction is
to this sentence of eight years
imprisonment for pc benjamin monk
becky johnson thank you